so we had a super busy day yesterday the
last three of the roughly oh I don't
know 14 hours or so of content that we
did yesterday in addition to the
impeachment hearings was Democratic
presidential debate number five this one
was on MSNBC they no longer even
pretended to really even try to hear
from every candidate on the stage
equally I believe Tom Styer spoke two to
three times Andrew yang maybe three or
four
I think tulsi gabbard about the same
amount of time and I understand it I
mean the stage at this point is filled
with people who have no chance of being
the nominee and it's important to hear
from the people who we might actually
vote for who might actually have a shot
of winning but I still think that the
solution then is make the debate
requirements tougher to meet don't keep
putting ten people on the stage when
half of no shot at least half of no shot
and mostly ignore them other than going
to them every once in a while but
nonetheless yesterday's debate featured
a whole bunch of Miss steps it had some
funny moments but basically I don't
think it will make a difference to
anyone's polling in any serious way it
might hurt Biden a tiny bit might help
Buddha judge a tiny bit but otherwise
it's basically what was expected and as
I've said before the further into the
primary we get the less each debate will
have the possibility of significantly
moving the polls now on foreign policy
and I tweeted about this it was really a
fiasco back when Andrew yang still paid
attention to me before he started
ignoring our show I had discussed with
him foreign policy is what separates the
knowledgeable from the clueless in
debates of length because it's much
easier on domestic policy to have more
than just a bullet point or two without
really know anything and knowing
anything with it whereas on foreign
policy it becomes much more obvious you
don't know anything and if in a debate
they ask a specific pointed foreign
policy question as they did yesterday
and what was there were some wacky
questions like asking Bernie if he
supports or denounces what random people
at some of his rallies chanted other
than some weird things like that it was
actually a pretty well run debate
skipping introductory statements was
smart and they asked some of these
pointed foreign policy Quest
and it became very clear that a lot of
the people on the stage either don't
have a clue or don't want to say what
their positions are and they reflexively
go into just attacking Donald Trump
which happened last night a lot and I
hate to say this because I'm not
supporting them and I don't think that
they are progressives the people who
actually answered the foreign policy
questions yesterday without just going
into bullet points or attacking Trump
were Joe Biden and Amy Klobuchar Amy has
no shot Biden has a shot but he's very
centrist not a progressive but they
actually answered the foreign policy
questions in addition to skipping
opening statements the moderators did a
pretty good job of exposing that a lot
of the candidates lacked deep knowledge
on a variety of issues that includes
foreign policy and I have said it before
at this point in the game there's a ton
of anti Trump stuff in in the
impeachment hearings the debates can't
be about here's why Trump is bad one
strange moment was when Elizabeth Warren
was asked if we should have a bigger
military and she said yes I think she
was sort of confused almost by the
question but here's how she answered
only about 1% of Americans serve in the
United States military right now should
that number be higher yes I think it
should be so this was weird because we
already have by far the biggest military
way bigger than we've ever then we would
ever need and Warren is saying she wants
more people in the military now later
she went on to talk about I think
realizing that her answer wasn't the
best and her campaign clarified well
she's talking about the Peace Corps and
volunteer opportunities and that type of
thing still a very strange way to answer
the question if that's what you mean yes
we need more people in the military
funniest moment was Cory Booker telling
Joe Biden that his position on cannabis
as a gateway drug was so weird that
Booker thought Joe Biden must have been
high when he said it I have a lot of
respect for for the vice president he is
sworn me into my office as a hero this
week I hear him literally say that I
don't think we should legalize marijuana
I thought you might've been high when
you said it
[Applause]
marijuana marijuana in our country is
already legal for privileged people
that's actually a funny line and Booker
had an OK night other than having no
chance whatsoever and you know have his
politics being what they are on the
optics which is what matters Booker
actually did okay one of the strangest
moments for Joe Biden was I misheard
what he said as Joe Biden's saying he
was the first black woman in the Senate
which of course was not what he said but
what he actually said was that he had
the support of the first black woman in
the Senate which created a weird dynamic
with Kamala Harris on the stage who said
something like I'm the other one and I'm
here it got weird take a look that's for
me because they know me they know who I
am three former chairs of the black
caucus the only black American woman
that ever been elected to the United
States Senate a whole range of people
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
to be vice president was because of my
relationship long-standing relationship
with the black community I was part of
that coalition yeah so that was
interesting a very strong moment for
Andrew yang was saying we need to
designate white supremacist violence as
domestic terrorism he got a good
reaction to that understandably he
should mr. yang what would you do about
the issue of white supremacist violence
well first we have to designate white
supremacist terrorism as domestic
terrorism so that the Department of
Justice can properly measure it
I talked to an anti hate activist named
Christian pitcher Leaney
who told me about how he was radicalized
over a 10-year period and he's right and
he mentions Christian Pete Cellini who's
been a guest on the show actually and
who I know he was recently in Boston
good moment for yang one of the few that
he got he did not get a lot of chance to
speak yesterday one of the bigger
moments of conflict was Kamala Harris
going after Tulsi Gabbard big time take
a look senator Harris any response oh
sure I I think that it's unfortunate
that we have someone on the stage who is
attempting to be the Democratic nominee
for president the United States who
during the Obama administration spent
four years full time on Fox News
criticizing President Obama that who had
it full-time
that's what
criticizing people on this stage at the
ated with the Democratic Party when
Donald Trump was elected not even sworn
in buddied up to Steve Bannon to get a
meeting with Donald Trump
in the Trump Tower fails to call a war
criminal by what he is as a war criminal
and then spends full time during the
course of this campaign again
criticizing the Democratic Party it was
an attack but it fell sort of flat but
maybe that's because I mean listen when
I want to hear about the specifics of
how Warren and Bernie will implement and
pay for their health care plans and then
I see someone polling 4.3% attacking
someone polling 2% it's hard for me to
really care that much about that and
then you wonder why aren't people who
with a shot at winning actually talking
policy here it's hard to get super
excited about these attacks I know a lot
of people loved Tulsi on it and then a
lot of people said look at look at
Kamala smacking down to I was like why
aren't we hearing from people with a
shot one other funny moment Andrew yang
was asked what would you say to Putin on
your first call as president of the US
and here's what he had to say
mr. yang if you in the 2020 election
what would you say in your first call
with Russian President Vladimir Putin
well first I'd say I'm sorry I beat your
guy
sorry sorry okay so listen this debate
was competitive in that many people did
well enough I don't believe anybody was
hugely damaged I don't think anybody
made any big progress there were no real
kill shots as I called them the one
thing I can sort of think of was a cory
booker saying I thought Joe Biden was
high when he said marijuana is a gateway
drug it was funny but it's it's widely
inconsequential Biden's position is just
wrong
and Booker has no shot now one thing
that is really insane and infuriating is
that Tom Styer was on the stage a lot of
people forgot because by the end of the
beta that the debate he wasn't talking
it seemed like he was you know at that
point trying to get his parking
validated and get on out of there but
Tom Styer has spent 50 million dollars
of his own money to pull 1% and get
himself on the debate stage he has no
shot he never did but think about what
he could have done with that 50 million
dollars if if Tom Steyer said I'm not
gonna run but I'm willing to put 50
million into the 2020 election he could
have put 50 million into the 5 key
Senate races that Democrats need to take
over control in 2020 of the Senate he
could have fixed the water problem in
Flint Michigan which is still a problem
he could have put 50 million into voter
registration drives to increase turnout
in fight voter suppression in 2020 which
could help get rid of Donald Trump my
point is almost any other use of Tom's
tires 50 million dollars would have left
Democrats better off than simply having
another guy polling 1% on the debate
stage let me know if you believe this
debate will move the needle for anyone
again the longer this goes the less any
one debate will move the needle unless
somebody really gaffes we need fewer
people on the stage in the next debate
number six is on December 19th it's the
day before we start our winter break so
we will be around for that debate and
streaming live so far six candidates
have qualified for that one Biden
Sanders Warren Gouda judge Harris
Klobuchar you've got Tom Styer and
Andrew yang pending nobody else has met
any of the requirements so hopefully we
will be down to six or at the most maybe
seven by the next debate let me know
winners losers what did you think I'm on
Twitter at Deep
and the show is on twitter at david
pakman show one of today's sponsors is
privacy dot-com slash Pakman this is a
free service that I've actually been
using myself for a while now and I love
it you just take a few seconds to link
your debit card or bank account to
privacy coms mobile app or browser
extension for Firefox and Chrome and
what that does is allow you to instantly
create virtual credit cards that are
linked to your bank account so that
you're not actually putting your real
debit card number on the Internet and
you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below